This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要表现出来。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。请在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的报应。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好，我是杰玛·斯佩克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要剖析
psychology of our 20s. Here is a story I hear a lot from listeners of the show. It is the story of someone being fresh out of college, fresh out of uni, getting their first job, starting a new job, being super optimistic and excited. and they're excited for the security and for the paycheck and like for the beginning of something new. And then a few months in, they encounter someone who just like wants to make their life miserable, whether that is a colleague, whether that is a boss, or they realize like, hey, like, wait a second, this workplace literally feels like I'm back in high school. Why does this person have an issue with me?
20多岁的心理学。这是一个我经常从节目听众那里听到的故事。这是一个刚从大学毕业，刚从学校出来，找到第一份工作，开始新工作，超级乐观和兴奋的人的故事。他们对安全感、薪水以及新事物的开始感到兴奋。然后几个月后，他们遇到了一个只想让他们的生活变得痛苦的人，无论是同事还是老板，或者他们意识到，嘿，等等，这个工作场所感觉就像我回到了高中。为什么这个人对我有什么意见？
Why are these people sleeping together? Why did I not get that promotion when I obviously work harder? or why does this person just hate me? I hear a story about this probably every week, a story about office politics, about drama and backstabbing and affairs and stuff that, honestly, nobody prepares us for in the workplace. We spend so much time at work. And office politics and situations like this do not get enough credit for how stressful they can be. Because often part of the stress is we have zero idea what to do.
为什么这些人要睡在一起？为什么我明明工作更努力却没有得到晋升？或者为什么这个人就是讨厌我？我几乎每周都会听到这样的故事，关于办公室政治、关于戏剧性事件、背后捅刀子和绯闻，老实说，没有人为我们在工作场所准备好应对这些。我们在工作中花费了太多时间。而办公室政治和类似这样的情况，对于它们可能带来的压力，并没有得到足够的重视。因为通常压力的一部分是我们完全不知道该怎么办。
especially in our 20s, we feel so helpless. Our work begins to suffer. We feel pessimistic about work in general. But how you go about managing these situations is going to shape your career deeply and possibly for the better. And if you have the right tools, your approach to office politics could actually make you more successful. Today, I want to give you a bit of that guide into the psychology that drives these hidden social mechanisms in the workplace. And kind of the reminder that we need that all of this is just complex human behavior boiled down into petty drama. Behind the scenes of all of this is secret motivations, emotions, human psychology that is
特别是在我们20多岁的时候，我们感到非常无助。我们的工作开始受到影响。我们对工作整体感到悲观。但你如何管理这些情况将深刻地塑造你的职业生涯，而且可能是向好的方向发展。如果你有正确的工具，你处理办公室政治的方法实际上可以让你更成功。今天，我想为你提供一点关于驱动工作场所这些隐藏社会机制的心理学指南。并提醒我们需要记住，所有这一切都只是复杂的、归结为琐碎戏剧性事件的人类行为。这一切的幕后是秘密的动机、情绪、人类心理，这些都在
influencing why people are the way we are or the way they are. And when we understand that psychology, we understand that research and that science, We have a better emotional playbook for dealing with this and for rising above some of like the terrible frustrating things that workplace politics is going to throw at us. So this is what we're discussing today. It's going to be a big episode, but a very worthwhile, essential one. If you are just beginning your career or in your 20s, without further ado, let's get into it. A lot of the time, I think our early 20s and our 20s in general,
影响着人们为什么是我们现在的样子，或者他们为什么是现在的样子。当我们理解了那种心理学，理解了那些研究和科学，我们就有了更好的情感剧本，来处理这些问题，并超越工作场所政治将抛给我们的那些可怕的、令人沮丧的事情。所以这就是我们今天要讨论的内容。这将是重要的一集，但非常值得，非常必要。如果你刚刚开始你的职业生涯，或者正处于20多岁，事不宜迟，让我们开始吧。很多时候，我认为我们20出头和20多岁的时候，
is like the first time we're really exposed to like very interesting and secretive workplace dynamics. I don't remember ever thinking about this before I started working. Yes, university, maybe high school had these like subtle hierarchies. Same as like some of our early jobs. But only as you get older do you realize how strange and like manipulative people can be and like the unwritten rules that are at play in the workplace. That is the office politics we're talking about. There is a literal whole and I mean major, major discipline of psychology, devoted to this very thing, by the way. It's called organizational psychology. It essentially exclusively focuses on why people behave the way they do at work, because we know work is such a huge part of our human lives and human identity. It makes sense that
是第一次真正接触到非常有趣和隐秘的工作场所动态。我不记得在开始工作之前考虑过这个问题。是的，大学，也许高中也有这些微妙的等级制度。和我们早期的一些工作一样。但只有当你变老时，你才会意识到人们是多么奇怪和具有操纵性，以及工作场所中存在着哪些不成文的规则。这就是我们正在谈论的办公室政治。顺便说一句，有一个字面上的整体，我的意思是主要的、主要的心理学学科，专门研究这个东西。它被称为组织心理学。它基本上专门关注人们为什么在工作中表现出他们现在的行为，因为我们知道工作是我们人类生活和人类身份的巨大组成部分。这很有道理，
it is as complicated as relationships, as complicated as marriages, as family. So back to the office. If you want to understand the complexities of office politics, you first have to understand that every office has, or every workplace has two structures, the formal hierarchy and the informal network. So on paper, the hierarchy is very clear. You know, you have managers, directors, executives, interns, etc., etc. This is like bureaucratic authority, right? The people at the top have legitimate rule-based power over people at the bottom. You know, who has the title, who does the budget? who does the performance reviews, who is in charge. Alongside this, though, is another structure that is more influential. This is the informal network. So these are the relationships. These are the relationships that determine who gets consulted, who actually shapes the decisions, who is actually trusted with sensitive information,
它和人际关系一样复杂，和婚姻一样复杂，和家庭一样复杂。所以回到办公室。如果你想了解办公室政治的复杂性，你首先必须了解每个办公室，或者每个工作场所都有两个结构，正式的等级制度和非正式的网络。所以在纸面上，等级制度非常清晰。你知道，你有经理、总监、高管、实习生等等。这就像官僚权威，对吧？处于顶层的人对处于底层的人拥有合法的、基于规则的权力。你知道，谁拥有头衔，谁负责预算？谁负责绩效评估，谁负责管理。然而，与此同时，还有另一个结构更具影响力。这就是非正式网络。所以这些是人际关系。这些是决定谁被咨询、谁真正塑造决策、谁真正被信任处理敏感信息的人际关系，
and then also who makes more money, who gets the promotions, even if that power structure doesn't line up with the formal power structure. This is sometimes what they call the shadow organization. It's like these unspoken channels of influence that you have to be aware of if you want to play the game of work. There is this classic theory from the 50s about the five main sources of workplace power. And this is the other thing you have to be aware of if you want to navigate the complexities of office life. If you want to have influence at work, you can have one of these five forms of power. legitimate power, so the kind of power that is granted by authority, reward power, power in your
还有谁赚更多的钱，谁得到晋升，即使那个权力结构与正式的权力结构不一致。这有时被称为影子组织。如果你想玩职场游戏，你必须意识到这些不成文的影响力渠道。有一个来自50年代关于工作场所权力五个主要来源的经典理论。如果你想驾驭办公室生活的复杂性，这是你必须意识到的另一件事。如果你想在工作中拥有影响力，你可以拥有这五种权力形式之一。合法权力，即由权威授予的那种权力；奖励权力，即你
ability to provide benefits, praise, recognition, coercive power, the power to punish, expert power, the power of knowledge and competence, and finally, reverent power, the ability to influence things through charisma and through likeability. In your 20s, like you, you You likely don't have much legitimate power yet. And I mean, if you do, that's amazing. Like, that's really cool if you are the CEO or something. But most people in their 20s don't decide how much people get paid. You can't really fire or hire en masse.
提供福利、赞美、认可的能力；强制权力，即惩罚的权力；专家权力，即知识和能力的权力；最后，参照权力，即通过魅力和讨人喜欢来影响事物的能力。在你20多岁的时候，你可能还没有多少合法权力。我的意思是，如果你有，那太棒了。如果你是首席执行官什么的，那真的很酷。但大多数20多岁的人并不决定人们的薪水。你不能真正大规模地解雇或雇佣。
What you do have, though, is referent and expert power. You can become indispensable by developing, you know, the knowledge and the skills that other people don't have time for. And they need to rely on you to do. You can also build alliances. You can collaborate with people. You can be nice to people. If you've ever heard the term personality hire, this is what we're talking about. People always dismiss the personality hire. But all that means is that you have great soft skills. You are enjoyable to be around. You're a morale booster. You are a fresh perspective. That is a huge asset in your 20s when a lot of people are very jaded. You have something,
然而，你确实拥有的是参照权力和专家权力。你可以通过发展其他人没有时间去做的知识和技能，变得不可或缺。他们需要依赖你来完成工作。你也可以建立联盟。你可以与人合作。你可以对人友善。如果你听说过“人格雇佣”这个词，这就是我们正在谈论的。人们总是看不起人格雇佣。但这仅仅意味着你拥有很棒的软技能。你是一个让人相处愉快的人。你是一个士气助推器。你是一个新鲜的视角。在你20多岁时，当很多人都非常厌倦时，这是一个巨大的资产。你拥有一些，
others don't. You have to use whatever you can, including that to your advantage. You being a nice person to be around helps your boss. It strokes their ego. It makes them feel good, which, yeah, may not be able to outperform somebody who is making three times as much as you. You may not be able to outperform a very complex skill, but that small addition on top of the other things you're doing and the other skills you do have gives you great power. You give something, you are giving your personality, they are getting something in return from that. One of the most useful psychological frameworks for office politics is basically exactly this. It's called social exchange theory. It was first proposed by George Homan's like in the 50s. I think it was further developed in the 60s. You'll hear social exchange theory
别人没有的东西。你必须利用你能利用的一切，包括这一点来发挥你的优势。你作为一个让人相处愉快的人，有助于你的老板。它抚慰了他们的自我。这让他们感觉良好，这，是的，可能无法胜过一个薪水是你三倍的人。你可能无法胜过一项非常复杂的技能，但除了你正在做的其他事情和你确实拥有的其他技能之外，那一点点小的补充给了你巨大的权力。你给予了一些东西，你正在给予你的个性，他们从那里面得到了回报。办公室政治最实用的心理学框架之一基本上就是这个。它被称为社会交换理论。它最初是由乔治·霍曼斯在50年代提出的。我想它在60年代得到了进一步发展。你会听到社会交换理论
talked about in everything from relationships to work to our pets. But it essentially suggests that all human relationships, all relationships in general, operate on a principle of exchange. We give and we receive resources, whether that is material resources like money, emotional resources like love and respect, relationships thrive when the exchange is balanced and they suffer when they feel one-sided. In an office, this shows up constantly. This exchange theory is literally the basis of all office politics. You help a co-worker meet a deadline. They later advocate for you during like promotion time. You share credit. Others share credit with you. You make your boss feel hip and young and cool and fun. They're going to be a nice boss. Back to you. You're going to get stuff in return.
在从人际关系到工作再到我们的宠物的一切中被谈论。但它基本上表明，所有的人际关系，所有的一般关系，都基于交换原则运作。我们给予和接收资源，无论是物质资源如金钱，还是情感资源如爱和尊重，当交换平衡时，关系就会蓬勃发展，而当它们感到单方面时，关系就会受损。在办公室里，这种情况不断出现。这种交换理论实际上是所有办公室政治的基础。你帮助同事赶上截止日期。他们后来在晋升时为你辩护。你分享功劳。其他人与你分享功劳。你让你的老板感到时髦、年轻、酷和有趣。他们会成为一个好老板。回到你身上。你会得到回报。
The social exchange theory is balanced. The exchange theory is balanced, basically. On the flip side, it also explains why the energy of an office can become really toxic. If you feel like, and I think this is an experience a lot of us have when we're younger. If you feel like you are endlessly giving everything, your loyalty, your ideas, your evenings, and you are not receiving any recognition, any support, any money that is a surefire way for resentment to build. Just like you would get super frustrated at a friend or a romantic partner for never reciprocating plans, never reciprocating the effort you put into their birthday. Like, this is all happening at work. This is all happening at work. equally, except now it's with your co-workers and you arguably probably see them a lot more. And you
社会交换理论是平衡的。交换理论基本上是平衡的。另一方面，它也解释了为什么办公室的能量会变得非常糟糕。如果你觉得，我认为这是我们年轻时很多人都有的经历。如果你觉得你无休止地付出一切，你的忠诚、你的想法、你的夜晚，而你没有得到任何认可、任何支持、任何金钱，那是怨恨滋生的必经之路。就像你会因为朋友或浪漫伴侣从不回报计划、从不回报你为他们的生日所付出的努力而感到超级沮丧一样。就像，这一切都在工作中发生。这一切都在工作中发生。同样，只是现在是和你的同事，而且可以说你可能经常见到他们。而且你
also can't just end the relationship and walk away the way that you probably could do with a bad friend. Like they are there as much as you are. So this is why we cannot brush over this stuff psychologically. The workplace, like it isn't just a place we show up and we do a bit of work and we get a paycheck and we go home and it's all great. It is a stage where we perform parts of ourselves and parts of our identity, and it is a stage where we are performing a social dance, and we are seeking belonging like we do in any social environment. When you are rejected, when you are excluded, when you do not feel part of the social fabric of the office, or you do not feel like people are friendly to you or kind to you, this will genuinely erode your mental health. Belonging is one of
也不能像对待一个糟糕的朋友那样结束这段关系并走开。就像他们和你一样在那里。所以这就是为什么我们不能在心理上忽视这些东西。工作场所，它不仅仅是我们出现、做一点工作、拿一份薪水、然后回家，一切都很棒的地方。它是一个我们表演我们自己的一部分和我们身份的一部分的舞台，它是一个我们正在进行社交舞蹈的舞台，我们像在任何社交环境中一样寻求归属感。当你被拒绝，当你被排斥，当你感觉不到自己是办公室社会结构的一部分，或者你感觉不到人们对你友好或善良时，这会真正侵蚀你的心理健康。归属感是我们
our most essential, emotional and psychological needs, whether it is at home, in a relationship, out in the world, if you do not feel like you belong, you kind of collapse inwards. Studies in organizational psychology have shown us time and time again. Employees that perceive themselves to be outsiders, people who feel like they are being pushed out of the inner circle of work, they are going to experience much higher levels of anxiety, lower job performance, greater repeated intentions to quit. they also have poorer self-worth because like it or not, so much of our identity is tied up in our professional lives and is tied up in our professional career. You cannot avoid it. Whatever
最基本的情感和心理需求之一，无论是在家里、在人际关系中，还是在世界上，如果你感觉不到归属感，你就会有点向内崩溃。组织心理学的研究一次又一次地向我们展示。那些认为自己是局外人的员工，那些感觉自己被挤出工作核心圈子的人，他们会经历更高水平的焦虑、更低的工作表现、更强烈的反复辞职意图。他们也有更差的自我价值感，因为无论你喜欢与否，我们很大一部分身份与我们的职业生活和职业生涯联系在一起。你无法避免它。无论
relationship you have with your work, it's just a mere fact that you're spending so much time there that's going to mean you and your job and your career will quickly become quite enmeshed. And you and your co-workers and the relationship you have with them will quickly impact your mental health if it goes wrong. And the other thing about exclusion, because I think this is a big part of office politics that happens a lot to us in our 20s, but at any age. Like, the big thing about exclusion is that it actually consumes a lot of mental resources to be left out. Like, it consumes a lot of mental resources to constantly be hypervigilant towards who's in the kitchen, who isn't talking to me, who doesn't like me. It takes a lot of time away from our actual job.
你与你的工作有什么关系，仅仅是你花那么多时间在那里这一事实，就意味着你、你的工作和你的职业生涯很快就会变得相当纠缠在一起。如果你和你的同事以及你与他们的关系出了问题，它很快就会影响你的心理健康。关于排斥的另一件事，因为我认为这是办公室政治中很大的一部分，在我们20多岁时经常发生，但在任何年龄都会发生。就像，关于排斥的大事是，被冷落实际上消耗了大量的心理资源。就像，不断地对谁在厨房、谁不跟我说话、谁不喜欢我保持高度警惕，会消耗大量的心理资源。它占用了我们实际工作的大量时间。
job, our actual tasks. That means that we perform poorer, which means we get more criticism, which means we feel more excluded, which means that it just becomes this cycle of performance linked to exclusion that then creates poorer performance and worse exclusion. This is why office politics matters so much. It's not just about promotions and recognition. There is this hidden world of inclusion and status and validation. And the way those things, are distributed, that is going to directly impact your psychology as an employee and as a person outside of work. Okay, we're going to take a short break here because that's a lot of stuff all at once.
工作，我们实际的任务。这意味着我们的表现更差，这意味着我们得到更多的批评，这意味着我们感到更被排斥，这意味着它就变成了这种与排斥相关的表现循环，然后导致更差的表现和更严重的排斥。这就是为什么办公室政治如此重要。这不仅仅是关于晋升和认可。有一个隐藏的包容、地位和验证的世界。而这些东西分配的方式，将直接影响你作为员工和工作之外的人的心理。好吧，我们要在这里休息一下，因为那是一下子太多的东西了。
But when I return, let's talk about competition. Let's talk about gossip. And let's talk about how you can use workplace competitiveness to your advantage. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who talk about. take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
但当我回来时，让我们谈谈竞争。让我们谈谈八卦。让我们谈谈你如何利用职场竞争力来发挥你的优势。所以请留下来。《2%》。这就是谈论的人数。当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家以及更多人交谈，以看穿统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。
That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush, didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out
这就是《2%》，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以找到答案
on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill
在《Look Back at it》播客上。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second. episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
大谈80年代的快克。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我整天都愿意谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. So, that you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。所以，你正在完成那个句子。是的。我不认为有比这更重要的年份对黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了那个东西。我们还在追逐它，我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的成为一个好人。
Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争来证明真相。你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through, the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的报应。请收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Competition in the workplace, I think, is like the second worst thing about office politics. after exclusion and after obviously like workplace bullying and harassment. But competition is like is fierce. It can ruin us emotionally to feel like we are constantly on this hamster wheel of trying to be better than the next person or the person behind us, in front of us, beside us. I remember when I, I've had, I don't know what it is, but every, actually I've never had a
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。我认为工作场所的竞争是办公室政治中第二糟糕的事情，仅次于排斥，当然还有职场欺凌和骚扰。但竞争是激烈的。感觉我们不断地在试图比下一个人，或者我们身后、身前、身边的人更好的仓鼠轮上，这在情感上会毁了我们。我记得当我，我不知道是什么原因，但实际上我从来没有过一个
workplace that was not competitive. Even when I worked at the steak restaurant, when I worked at the steak restaurant in uni, I had this terrible boss who I talk about a lot because I, I, I hated this man and he was awful to us and he had this like hierarchy right of the employees that he liked and the employees that he didn't and there were two employees that he always really liked and then there were like 15 of us who were vying for like three other positions in that like top five slot and whether you are on the inn or the out with him would like determine if you got to leave early how many tips you got like what sections you're worked in and that environment created so much competition and like genuine like sabotage at like the
不具竞争力的工作场所。即使我在牛排餐厅工作时，当我在大学期间在牛排餐厅工作时，我有一个糟糕的老板，我经常谈论他，因为我，我，我讨厌这个人，他对我们很糟糕，他有一种等级制度，对吧，他喜欢的员工和不喜欢的员工，有两个员工他总是非常喜欢，然后有大约15个我们正在争夺那前五名位置中的其他三个职位，你和他关系好还是不好，决定了你是否可以早点下班，你得到了多少小费，你被安排在哪些区域工作，那种环境创造了如此多的竞争，甚至在
steak restaurant like I used to find it so funny that all these politicians and academics and like very wealthy people would be eating their I don't know medium rare steaks and behind the scenes there was like all these like 18 to 27 year olds who had like major workplace grief with each other or because of this environment that this man created all because of this competition. And then that happened again in like my corporate job and in the corporate environment that I worked in. There is this idea, like there was always not enough to go around. There was so much competition about who was staying the latest, who was putting in the craziest hours. It was like this badge of honor to have poor life boundaries, especially in your 20s when, again, we talk about the power that we have in
牛排餐厅里有真正的破坏行为。我过去常觉得很有趣，所有这些政客、学者和非常富有的人都在吃他们的，我不知道，三分熟的牛排，而在幕后，有所有这些18到27岁的人，他们因为这个男人创造的环境，因为这种竞争，彼此之间有重大的职场不满。然后这种情况又在我的企业工作中发生了，在我工作的企业环境中。有一种想法，就像总是不够分。关于谁留得最晚，谁投入了最疯狂的时间，竞争非常激烈。拥有糟糕的生活界限就像是一种荣誉勋章，特别是在你20多岁的时候，当我们再次谈论我们在
our 20s, a lot of the power that we have is that we can do the brunt work. That's how we get ahead is by doing the things nobody else wants to do. Back to this competition thing. Why? Why do workplaces get so competitive? It's because they are often structured around scarce resources. This is really what it comes down to. It is a resource problem. Bonuses, promotions, who likes who. There's not enough to go around. There's not enough love, admiration, money, corner offices, so that everybody can get one. This can very easily turn colleagues into rivals. It is like a tailor's oldest time. We know in psychology that the scarcity effect makes and turns us into irrational creatures. When something seems more rare or less available,
20多岁时拥有的权力时，我们拥有的很多权力是我们能做繁重的工作。我们如何领先就是通过做别人不想做的事情。回到这个竞争问题。为什么？为什么工作场所变得如此具有竞争性？这是因为它们通常围绕稀缺资源构建。这真的是归结为资源问题。奖金、晋升、谁喜欢谁。没有足够的东西分给每个人。没有足够的爱、钦佩、金钱、角落办公室，让每个人都能得到一个。这很容易把同事变成竞争对手。这是自古以来的故事。我们在心理学中知道，稀缺效应使我们变成了非理性的生物。当某样东西看起来更稀有或更不可用时，
this changes how we react to that thing. And it means that we often do things we wouldn't. because something seems exclusive or rare and therefore we want it more. Competition is always going to exist in the workplace, especially if you're in a very corporate competitive job market, but psychology tells us that how we interpret competition is going to change its emotional and vocational impact on us. Competition can be informational or emotional. We want it to be informational.
这改变了我们对那件事的反应。这意味着我们经常做我们不会做的事情。因为某样东西看起来是排他的或稀有的，因此我们更想要它。竞争总是会存在于工作场所，特别是如果你在一个非常企业化、竞争激烈的就业市场中，但心理学告诉我们，我们如何解读竞争将改变它对我们的情感和职业影响。竞争可以是信息性的或情感性的。我们希望它是信息性的。
That is what we're aspiring to, is when it is framed in this way, when it is framed as something that is helping us to understand where we stand, helping us notice our weaknesses, helping us push ourselves further, it can actually motivate growth. When it is framed as emotional or threatening, a scarce game like the one we're in means that somebody else's success is always going to mean our failure. And that's going to trigger envy, it's going to trigger defensiveness. More crucially, though, it's going to trigger more rash behavior. that's actually going to make you look worse and make you or turn you into somebody who is
这就是我们所追求的，当它以这种方式被框架时，当它被框架为某种帮助我们了解我们所处位置、帮助我们注意到我们的弱点、帮助我们推动自己走得更远的东西时，它实际上可以激励成长。当它被框架为情感性的或威胁性的时，像我们所处的这种稀缺游戏意味着别人的成功总是意味着我们的失败。这会触发嫉妒，触发防御性。然而，更关键的是，它会触发更鲁莽的行为。这实际上会让你看起来更糟，让你变成一个
anti-social, who could even do bad things. Social psychologists really like to get into the needy-gritty of the distinction here. And they like to distinguish between benign envy, which motivates self-improvement and malicious envy, which actually just motivates tearing others down. And in the process, we should say, destroying us. more. Destroying us because it makes us look bad, destroying us because it takes all of our concentration and energy we should be putting towards our goals and our work and it turns it towards somebody else. I truly believe competition and envy are some of the most powerful states of mind that you can find yourself in because they actually, they deeply reveal what we
反社会的人，甚至可能做坏事。社会心理学家非常喜欢深入研究这里的区别。他们喜欢区分良性嫉妒，它激励自我提升，和恶意嫉妒，它实际上只是激励拆台。在这个过程中，我们应该说，摧毁我们。更多。摧毁我们，因为它让我们看起来很糟糕，摧毁我们，因为它占用了我们应该投入到我们的目标和工作中的所有注意力和精力，并将其转向别人。我真心相信竞争和嫉妒是你可能发现自己处于的最强大的心态之一，因为它们实际上，它们深刻地揭示了我们
want in life. It's probably one of the easiest ways to know what you desire. Who are you jealous of? Who do you really envy? Because if they're wasn't something about them you secretly actually admired and wanted or secretly found impressive, you wouldn't be jealous of it because it wouldn't be something that you secretly wanted and aspired towards. This knowledge can actually bolster your performance. There was a 2008 study, I don't know what university it was done at, maybe Brown, and it found that exposure to high achieving peers boosted performance when, when the other participants saw their success as inspiring rather than threatening. So when they saw somebody doing really well and they were like, wow, that's incredible. I really want to be like them.
在生活中想要什么。这可能是了解你渴望什么的最简单方法之一。你嫉妒谁？你真正羡慕谁？因为如果他们身上没有你私下里真正钦佩和想要的东西，或者私下里觉得令人印象深刻的东西，你就不会嫉妒它，因为它不会是你私下里想要和追求的东西。这种知识实际上可以增强你的表现。2008年有一项研究，我不知道是在哪所大学做的，可能是布朗大学，它发现当其他参与者将他们的成功视为鼓舞人心而不是威胁时，接触高成就的同龄人会提高表现。所以当他们看到有人做得非常好，他们就像，哇，那太不可思议了。我真的想变得像他们一样。
It didn't eliminate competition. It made competition a game. It made it something fun. It made it a motivational resource that they could use to their advantage. It became like a superpower. even if like even if the other people around you don't feel the same like even if you are the only one who wants to treat competition this way in your workplace amongst your peers it is not like a i guess not a zero-sum game like not everybody has to play for the game to still go your way you will still come out exponentially better if you can do the mindset and the psychological and the emotional work to turn competition from emotional into informational. Listen, I kind of get it.
它并没有消除竞争。它使竞争成为一种游戏。它使它成为某种有趣的东西。它使它成为他们可以利用的激励资源。它变得像一种超能力。即使，即使你周围的其他人在感觉上不一致，即使你是唯一一个想在你的工作场所、在你的同龄人中以这种方式对待竞争的人，它也不是一个，我想不是一个零和游戏，不是每个人都必须玩，游戏才能仍然按你的方式进行。如果你能做心态和心理以及情感工作，将竞争从情感转化为信息，你仍然会变得指数级更好。听着，我有点明白。
Like, you can have that mindset, and there's always going to be somebody who doesn't. And there's always going to be somebody who is going to take it too far. I think few dynamics feel worse than realizing a colleague is actively trying to make you look bad. Whether it is withholding information, subtle digs, questioning your competence in front of other people, gossiping about you, Psychologists have a name for this. It's called social undermining. It is deliberate behaviors that chip away at somebody's like reputation and even at their own ability to get work done or to get
就像，你可以有那种心态，但总会有人没有。而且总会有人会做得太过分。我认为很少有动态比意识到同事正在积极地试图让你看起来很糟糕感觉更糟。无论是隐瞒信息、微妙的挖苦、在别人面前质疑你的能力、八卦你，心理学家给这起了一个名字。它被称为社会破坏。这是故意削弱某人的声誉，甚至削弱他们自己完成工作或完成
things done. The hypervigilance this creates is its own level of exhaustion. You are basically going to work on the defense, eight hours a day, five days a week, more for some. That is going to change your stress response, change your emotional response, change how you react in work and outside of work. I don't want to discount that in the slightest. If you are going through something like this at the moment where a boss hates you, a colleague hates you, somebody is undermining you, somebody obviously doesn't want you to succeed and is setting you up for failure, it is very easy to maybe dismiss that and think, oh, it's just work. It doesn't really matter. like I'll get through it, but it is probably deeply impacting you.
事情的能力的行为。这所创造的高度警惕性本身就是一种疲劳。你基本上每天工作八小时，每周五天，有些人更多，都在防御状态。这会改变你的压力反应，改变你的情感反应，改变你在工作和工作之外的反应。我一点也不想低估这一点。如果你现在正在经历这样的事情，老板讨厌你，同事讨厌你，有人在破坏你，有人显然不希望你成功，并让你失败，这很容易被忽视，认为，哦，这只是工作。这真的没关系，就像我会度过难关的，但它可能正在深刻地影响你。
So I want you to know I have a lot of empathy for that, a lot of sympathy for the situation you're in. There are some things you can do, though, that are going to make the situation not better, but more preferable for you. This is what I think you can do if you were in that hyper-competitive, maybe saboteur situation. Firstly, information tracking, note-taking. archiving is your best friend right now. Dates, what was said, what was done, any witnesses. This might feel pretty bureaucratic and maybe petty at first. But if this person genuinely doesn't
所以我希望你知道我对这一点有很多同情，对你所处的处境有很多同情。不过，你可以做一些事情，让情况不是变得更好，而是对你来说更可取。如果你处于那种高度竞争、可能是破坏者的处境中，我认为你可以这样做。首先，信息跟踪、笔记记录。存档是你现在最好的朋友。日期、说了什么、做了什么、任何证人。这起初可能感觉相当官僚，也许很琐碎。但如果这个人真的不
like you and it reaches the point where their behavior is really injuring your reputation or it becomes workplace bullying, this just gives you some leverage. It gives you something that you can escalate to HR and be like, hey, I'm not crazy. This is what has been done. When it comes to, that's a long-term strategy. When it comes to responding in the moment, the hardest part is that you have to stay strategic rather than reactive. Half the time, a reaction is what people want. Even if it's not, it will help them. You having an immediate, angry, furious, loud reaction is going to do them favors. It's so unfair because all you want to do is stand up for yourself, but you have to try and stick to facts, not feelings. Keep it really simple. Responses like, I noticed X happened in the meeting. Can you
喜欢你，并且到了他们的行为真的损害了你的声誉或者变成了职场欺凌的地步，这只是给了你一些筹码。它给了你一些你可以升级到人力资源部的东西，说，嘿，我没疯。这就是已经做过的事情。当谈到，这是一个长期策略。当谈到在当下做出反应时，最困难的部分是你必须保持战略性而不是反应性。有一半的时间，反应是人们想要的。即使不是，它也会帮助他们。你有一个立即的、愤怒的、激烈的、大声的反应会帮他们的忙。这太不公平了，因为你只想为自己挺身而出，但你必须尝试坚持事实，而不是感受。保持非常简单。像“我注意到会议中发生了X。你能”这样的回应
explain that to me? I noticed that you said this. I don't understand why that's funny. I noticed that you didn't send me that. Was there a reason? The use of questions against a bully or against somebody who was competitive is the most important thing you can do because it shifts the need to explain and justify back onto them. And it will very quickly show like the gaps in their story. or the moments that don't add up to people outside of the situation. That's not to say your emotions are not important. They act as a compass, they validate your experience, they point out what's not okay, but giving someone direct access to those emotions right now is giving them a bit of a strategic advantage
能给我解释一下吗？我注意到你说了这句话。我不明白这有什么好笑的。我注意到你没把那个发给我。是有什么原因吗？对霸凌者或竞争对手使用提问技巧是你所能做的最重要的事情，因为它将解释和辩解的压力重新推回给了对方。这能很快暴露出他们故事中的漏洞，或者让局外人看出那些逻辑不通的地方。这并不是说你的情绪不重要。它们就像指南针，能验证你的感受，指出哪些是不对的，但现在就让对方直接触碰你的情绪，等于给了他们一点战略优势。
because they now know what hurts you most, where they can deliver blows to make sure that you hurt, where things sting, how to get what they want from you, try and keep them private from the person who is frustrating you, I don't know, I was going to say interrogating you, but from the person who is obviously trying to make your life a bit more miserable. Here's a final major tip that I know from experience can be so hard to avoid, but really try not to mirror their behavior. Retaliation feels so satisfying, biologically, emotionally, but it entrenches the toxicity and it really can cause damage to your reputation.
因为他们现在知道什么最能伤害你，知道从哪里下手能让你痛苦，知道你的痛点在哪里，知道如何从你身上得到他们想要的。尽量对那个让你沮丧的人——我本来想说审问你的人，但就是那个明显想让你的生活变得更糟糕的人——保持隐私。这里有一个我从经验中得出的重要建议，虽然很难做到，但真的尽量不要模仿他们的行为。报复在生理和情感上确实让人感到满足，但它会加剧这种有毒的氛围，并可能真正损害你的声誉。
By staying professional, staying composed, you gain power. You become the person, others see as reliable, other see as steady and competent, the one who rises above the drama. Over time, that credibility is your biggest asset because it acts as armor. And those colleagues, that boss, that manager who is trying to undermine you, loses their influence against that steadiness. Let's talk about one final aspect of workplace office politics that I'm just realizing we haven't touched on at all, which is bizarre because it's so, so vital. I'm going to give you guys like two seconds to guess. We're going to talk about gossip.
保持专业和冷静，你就能获得力量。你会成为别人眼中可靠、稳重、能干的人，一个能超越纷争的人。随着时间的推移，这种信誉是你最大的资产，因为它就像盔甲一样。而那些试图破坏你的同事、老板或经理，在你的这种稳重面前会失去影响力。让我们谈谈职场办公室政治的最后一个方面，我刚意识到我们还没触及到，这很奇怪，因为它非常、非常重要。我给你们两秒钟猜一下。我们要谈谈八卦。
This is the question we all want to know the answer to. Should you gossip at work? Simple question, strangely complicated answer. Gossip is complicated because it is social currency. It is the social currency of the workplace. When you have information, nobody else knows. That is a commodity. That is a commodity to trade. It's a way to socially bond as well. Whether we like to admit it or not, like,
这是我们都想知道答案的问题。你应该在工作中聊八卦吗？简单的问题，答案却出奇地复杂。八卦很复杂，因为它是一种社交货币。它是职场的社交货币。当你拥有别人不知道的信息时，那是一种商品。那是一种可以交易的商品。它也是一种社交联结的方式。不管我们愿不愿意承认，比如，
people who gossip do have more power. And sometimes, let's be real, they are more fun. But frequent, exclusively negative gossip will carry real costs. And it's something that especially if you're in your 20s, you need to avoid, despite like the allure of like the immediate benefit of dopamine. Like gossip brings dopamine. It brings oxytocin. It's bonding. A 2024 study though from researchers at the, I think, University of Leeds in the UK, they actually found that it will often make you look worse. They conducted a series of studies with like 1,400 participants. They basically presented them
爱聊八卦的人确实拥有更多权力。而且说实话，有时候他们更有趣。但频繁且纯粹的负面八卦会带来真正的代价。尤其是如果你才20多岁，你需要避免这种情况，尽管它有带来多巴胺的即时诱惑。八卦确实能带来多巴胺。它能带来催产素。它是一种联结。然而，英国利兹大学的研究人员在2024年的一项研究发现，它通常会让你看起来更糟糕。他们对1400名参与者进行了一系列研究。他们基本上向他们展示了
with a hypothetical workplace scenario with colleagues, with gossipers, with not people, who don't gossip. And what they found was that whilst the participants viewed the people who gossiped as more sociable, they often actually liked them more. They also viewed them as less moral, less competent, and they were less likely to trust them or provide them with promotions. In other words, gossip is like, is going to give you the short-term hit. It might grant you short-term inclusion, but it costs you credibility in the long run. It's a piece of advice my mom always used to give me. The worst person in the office is not the person that makes mistakes. It is the person who talks about them. So resist the urge, even when something feels juicy. I always like to assume,
一个假设的职场场景，里面有同事、有爱聊八卦的人，也有不聊八卦的人。他们发现，虽然参与者认为爱聊八卦的人更善于社交，甚至往往更喜欢他们，但他们同时也认为这些人道德感更低、能力更差，并且不太可能信任他们或给他们升职。换句话说，八卦能给你带来短期的快感。它可能让你获得短期的融入感，但从长远来看，它会让你付出信誉的代价。这是我妈妈常给我的建议。办公室里最糟糕的人不是犯错的人，而是谈论别人错误的人。所以要抵制这种冲动，即使有些事情听起来很劲爆。我总是喜欢假设，
like, the person is in the next room. The person can always overhear you. And I don't know, what do they say about reputation? Like, it takes five minutes to build a reputation that will last a lifetime. And if you want to gossip, if you don't want to be excluded from like the water fountain chat, research published in 2022 highlights that actually engaging in positive workplace gossip, talking good behind somebody's back, as Amy Pola says, that can actually make you more valuable. It can bolster social standing. It increases the rate and timing of promotions, the study found, and it makes you feel better at work. It's like nicotine replacement therapy for gossip or like junk food replacement therapy, like swap chocolate with dark chocolate, swap cruel gossip
那个人就在隔壁房间。那个人随时都能听到你的谈话。而且，关于声誉人们是怎么说的？建立一个持续一生的声誉需要五分钟。如果你想聊八卦，如果你不想被排除在茶水间的闲聊之外，2022年发表的研究强调，实际上参与积极的职场八卦，即在背后说别人的好话——正如艾米·波勒所说——实际上能让你更有价值。研究发现，这可以提升社会地位，增加升职的频率和时机，并让你在工作中感觉更好。这就像是八卦的尼古丁替代疗法，或者说是垃圾食品替代疗法，比如把巧克力换成黑巧克力，把恶毒的八卦
with positive gossip. Before we wrap up on our office politics episode, I want to share some final advice for managing these situations that I wish I'd known sooner. I was really reflecting on this when writing this episode because our 400th episode, my like three years, anniversary since quitting my job is coming up. And now that I've had some distance from like corporate life, I think there are some objective insights that I can share about my situation that hopefully you guys can take advantage of. So stay with us. We're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my
换成积极的八卦。在结束我们的办公室政治这一集之前，我想分享一些管理这些情况的最终建议，我希望我能早点知道。在写这一集时我一直在反思，因为我们的第400集，也就是我辞职三周年的纪念日快到了。现在我与企业生活保持了一定的距离，我想我可以分享一些关于我当时处境的客观见解，希望你们能从中受益。所以请留下来。在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的
podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships.
播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家交谈，看透那些主导健康产业、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们错了。世界上许多让我们感到恐慌的问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。就是“TWO%”。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖礼上拍了利尔·金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和利尔·金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克毒品。说清楚，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上讨论。谢谢你补全那句话。我不认为还有比这更重要的一年了，对黑人来说。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康宣传月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到
that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
我们已经拥有了那个东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要？还是因为你害怕才做一个好人？因为那是两种不同的动机。兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层级的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search, learn the hard way, and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”，立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这是一场长达数年的法庭斗争，旨在证明真相。你在这个特定的测试中作假了两次，对吧？我作假了一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man. should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。有两条金科玉律，任何男人都应该遵守。第一条，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我们总是说要相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定自己动手。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Like I said, it has been three years since I quit my corporate job to do, well, actually not three years.
我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将是他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。就像我说的，距离我辞去公司工作已经三年了，嗯，其实不是三年。
It's been like two and a half since I quit my corporate job to do the podcast full time. And I feel like in the kind of months and years after I quit that job, I always thought I was going to have to go back. And I always thought that I was, yeah, I was going to have to ask for my job back. So I never used to talk about work or like that job really on the podcast. But today I thought I'd do it. And I thought I'd kind of share some of the things that I'd learned and that I wish I'd done differently. The biggest one being, I wish, and I tell everybody this, the same. has nothing to do with office politics, just to do with being in an office. Use your sick leave. If you have paid sick leave, I need you to be taking a random, like, take those days off,
距离我辞去公司工作全职做播客已经两年半了。我觉得在我辞职后的几个月和几年里，我总是认为我不得不回去。我总是认为，是的，我不得不请求要回我的工作。所以我以前从不在播客上谈论工作或那份工作。但今天我想谈谈。我想分享一些我学到的东西，以及我希望我能做得不同的事情。最重要的一点是，我希望——我告诉每个人这一点——这与办公室政治无关，只是关于在办公室工作。使用你的病假。如果你有带薪病假，我需要你随机地，比如，请那些假，
even if you're not sick. I know that sounds bad. I don't really care. I genuinely think that, like, you pay for those days. If sick days, personal leave days were not, they are part of your workplace package. So if your work did not offer them, you would be getting more money. Do you know, I mean, like you are salary sacrificing in general to have these days off. So you have to use them. If you have recently quit a job or if you are about to quit the job that you just had, calling sick for like the whole week. And I know people are going to be like, that gives you a terrible reputation. That like really lets down your co-workers. Valid and maybe you're a better person than I am. But you will very, very,
即使你没生病。我知道这听起来不好。我不在乎。我真心认为，你付出了代价。如果病假、事假不是——它们是你职场福利的一部分。所以如果你的工作不提供这些，你会得到更多的钱。你知道我的意思吗，你基本上是在牺牲薪水来换取这些假期。所以你必须使用它们。如果你最近辞职了，或者如果你即将辞职，请假一周。我知道人们会说，这会让你名声扫地。这会让你的同事很失望。有道理，也许你比我更好。但你会非常、非常
quickly realize after you quit that job that it is not the whole world and it is not the whole universe, it's very easy to feel like the reputation you have at that workplace is going to follow you everywhere. Taking like a week of sick leave after you quit is not going to ruin your career. And in fact, I think it's probably good and will increase your performance at your next job to have that buffer. Second thing I would do if I wanted to get ahead, that one's not really a get ahead tip. That's just a fun tip. That's a lifestyle tip.
快地意识到，在你辞职后，那并不是整个世界，也不是整个宇宙。很容易觉得你在那个工作场所的声誉会跟随你到任何地方。辞职后请一周病假不会毁了你的职业生涯。事实上，我认为这可能很好，并且会提高你在下一份工作中的表现，因为你有了一个缓冲期。如果我想出人头地，我会做的第二件事，那不是什么出人头地的秘诀。那只是一个有趣的建议。那是一个生活方式的建议。
My second tip for like getting ahead at work though that I did at my old job, at all my corporate jobs, reply to every single email you are CCed in. Even the ones that like have nothing to do with you. Now obviously not like company wide email updates. But I mean if you are on a project and somebody ceases you just for visibility, always email back. Always email back with a question. Always email back with something or other.
不过，我为在工作中出人头地而提出的第二个建议，我在旧工作、在所有的公司工作中都做过，就是回复你被抄送的每一封电子邮件。即使是那些和你无关的邮件。当然不是指全公司范围的邮件更新。但我的意思是，如果你在一个项目中，有人为了可见性抄送你，一定要回复。一定要带着问题回复。一定要带着这样或那样的内容回复。
Just so that your name, especially if you were in like a hierarchical, like workplace, your name is visible. Like the effort that you put in is visible. These are easy reputation bonus points, especially if you're a junior, you know, it makes you seem super engaged. It costs you like five minutes a day. Third tip, do not burn bridges at work. Do not at any point, you know, know, decide, I don't need to be friends with this person. I don't need anything to do with this person. I am going to make the rash decision to just, like, to just cut them out. Or I'm bored by this person, or they're annoying me. So I'm going to stop replying to them, or I'm going to ignore them, or whatever it is. Like, even if this person is incredibly frustrating, even if you think you will
这样你的名字，特别是在等级森严的职场中，就会被看到。你付出的努力是可见的。这些是容易获得的声誉加分项，特别是如果你是初级员工，你知道，这让你看起来非常投入。这每天只花你五分钟。第三个建议，不要在工作中烧毁桥梁。不要在任何时候，你知道，决定，我不需要和这个人做朋友。我不需要和这个人有任何关系。我要做出草率的决定，直接切断联系。或者我对这个人感到厌烦，或者他们让我恼火。所以我不再回复他们，或者我忽略他们，或者诸如此类。即使这个人非常令人沮丧，即使你认为你
never see them again, even if they are some distant connection that has royally pissed you off, do not burn that bridge. I can promise you right now, that person will come back around. You will see that person again. At some point, that will be very awkward. Obviously, if they're like really awful, you're allowed to distance yourself. But never think you're above anybody, never think that you know more than anybody. Never let your ego get in the way of being kind and respectful to people because it will always come back to bite you. I would also say another big tip for my corporate people out there, my corporate 20-somethings. If your boss is doing your job for you, you are in trouble. I think this is like the clearest litmus test for like if you are doing well at work.
再也见不到他们了，即使他们是一些让你极其愤怒的远房关系，也不要烧毁那座桥。我现在可以向你保证，那个人会回来的。你会再次见到那个人。在某个时刻，那会非常尴尬。显然，如果他们真的很糟糕，你可以与他们保持距离。但永远不要认为你比任何人高人一等，永远不要认为你比任何人知道得多。永远不要让你的自负阻碍你对人友善和尊重，因为它总会反过来伤害你。我还要给我的公司职员、我的公司20多岁的朋友们一个大建议。如果你的老板在替你做你的工作，你就麻烦了。我认为这是衡量你工作是否做得好的最清晰的试金石。
if you are doing your job and you are doing it okay, even doing exceptionally doing okay, if you're just doing your job and your boss isn't constantly like, this is a mistake, I've had to fix this, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, you're doing all right. If you find that your boss is suddenly having to make corrections, having to ask you repeatedly for changes, if you're finding that like you submit something and it comes out in a completely different manner, that's when I would really be scheduling that one-on-one and being like, what can I do and how can I do more? Doing that shows so much incentive. Like genuinely, reaching out for feedback before feedback is provided gets you ahead of this
如果你在做你的工作，而且做得还可以，甚至做得非常出色，如果只是在做你的工作，而你的老板没有不断地说：“这是一个错误，我不得不修复这个，等等等等”，你做得还可以。如果你发现你的老板突然不得不进行更正，不得不反复要求你修改，如果你发现你提交的东西出来时完全变了样，那我会真的安排那次一对一谈话，问：“我能做什么，我怎样才能做得更多？”这样做表现出了很大的主动性。真心实意地，在提供反馈之前寻求反馈，让你领先于这个问题，
problem and gets you ahead of like, I don't know, not the consequences, but sometimes the embarrassment of not being told off, but being criticized. And when you get criticized like unexpectedly, that can be so painful. So that is my biggest tip. And also ask for help. People love it when you ask for help. They would rather that you ask for help than they have to ask you for corrections. That is something that when I was kind of a junior, I remember one of my mentors saying to me, which she was like, I would much rather feel needed before the fact than feel like, then feel like you are needy afterwards or feel like, I feel like, I suddenly have to do your job.
并让你领先于，我不知道，不是后果，但有时是没被责骂但被批评的尴尬。当你意外地受到批评时，那会非常痛苦。所以这是我最大的建议。还有，寻求帮助。人们喜欢你寻求帮助。他们宁愿你寻求帮助，也不愿他们不得不要求你进行更正。这是我还是初级员工时，我记得我的一位导师对我说过的话，她说：“我宁愿在事发前感到被需要，也不愿感到你事后需要帮助，或者觉得我不得不做你的工作。”
I'd much rather handhold than do myself if it means that the next time you are able to do it. My final thing, and this has nothing to do with office politics, workplace drama, perhaps slightly it does, but just like general career advice, you are allowed to leave your job. You're allowed to quit and you're allowed to quit at inopportune times. You're allowed to leave because you just don't want to be there anymore. you're allowed to let people down, even if they are mentors, even if they are bosses, you really want to impress.
如果这意味着下次你能做到，我宁愿手把手教你，也不愿自己做。我的最后一件事，这与办公室政治、职场戏剧无关，也许有一点关系，但只是通用的职业建议，你有权离开你的工作。你有权辞职，你有权在不合时宜的时候辞职。你有权离开，仅仅是因为你不想再待在那里了。你有权让人们失望，即使他们是导师，即使他们是你想给他们留下深刻印象的老板。
I think it's so important that we remember in our 20s especially. Like, this is just a job. This is just a job. As much as the hours that work demands from us now get us really enmeshed in the identity of work and in the identity of our career, at the end of the day, your whole life. life could fall apart and this would be the last thing you were thinking of, or hopefully it would be. Your whole life could fall apart and this workplace, this job could go and would go on without you. So make sure you have an identity outside of work.
我认为在20多岁时记住这一点非常重要。这只是一份工作。这只是一份工作。尽管工作现在对我们要求的工时让我们深深地陷入了工作的身份和职业的身份中，但归根结底，你的整个人生。生活可能会分崩离析，而这会是你最后想到的事情，或者希望是这样。你的整个人生可能会分崩离析，而这个工作场所、这份工作可能会消失，并且没有你也会继续下去。所以确保你在工作之外有自己的身份。
Make sure especially that you have friendships outside of work. Make sure that you are carving time outside of your job to be a human and not just a machine and not just a career or not just a workplace. Okay, that is my final tip for the day. I hope you enjoyed this episode and you enjoyed this little peek into the psychology behind office politics and how to navigate it a little bit better in our 20s. Thank you so much to our researcher Libby Colbert for her research contributions to this episode.
确保你在工作之外有友谊。确保你在工作之外抽出时间做一个人类，而不仅仅是一台机器，不仅仅是一个职业，不仅仅是一个工作场所。好了，这就是我今天的最后一个建议。希望你喜欢这一集，也喜欢这次对办公室政治背后的心理学以及如何在20多岁时更好地驾驭它的小小窥探。非常感谢我们的研究员利比·科尔伯特为这一集做出的研究贡献。
She is, as always, incredible. If you have made it this far, leave a comment down below. what was your first job? I feel like I've asked this question before. But yeah, what was your first job? Mine was at Boost Juice, a smoothie shop in Australia. So I want to know what yours were. Make sure that if you are in the US, Australia, UK, Canada, New Zealand, Southeast Asia,
她一如既往地令人难以置信。如果你已经看到了这里，在下方留下评论。你的第一份工作是什么？我觉得我以前问过这个问题。但是的，你的第一份工作是什么？我的是在澳大利亚的一家果昔店Boost Juice。所以我想知道你们的是什么。确保如果你在美国、澳大利亚、英国、加拿大、新西兰、东南亚，
that you watch us on Netflix. I feel like we all know, hopefully you guys all know this by now, but the podcast is on Netflix. So you can go and watch full episodes there if you feel called to do so. You can also just listen here. But make sure that you are following along or subscribed wherever you are listening so you get new episodes. You can follow us on Instagram. You can follow us on Substack.
你在Netflix上观看我们。我觉得我们都知道，希望你们现在都知道了，但这个播客在Netflix上。所以如果你有兴趣，可以去那里观看完整剧集。你也可以在这里收听。但请确保你在收听的地方关注或订阅，这样你就能获得新剧集。你可以在Instagram上关注我们。你可以在Substack上关注我们。
I feel like you guys hear this all the time. The links are in the description if you are searching for them. But until next time, be safe, be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available.
我觉得你们经常听到这个。如果你在寻找链接，它们就在描述中。但直到下次，注意安全，保持友善。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这是在有自动扶梯的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979 that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay
收听《2%》。就是“TWO%”。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中，对于1979年，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻，84年对我来说很重要，我是萨姆·杰伊。
And I'm Alex English Each episode we pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代，84年是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keir Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
我不认为还有比这更重要的一年了，对黑人来说。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都不太安全进行的诚实对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or. wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你在这个特定的测试中作假了两次，欧文斯女士，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped.
我作假了一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过，她们决定自己动手。我发誓，我将是他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说要相信你的女朋友们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。